what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about the latest and craziest
updates in the Dimas Aires story the
fight between Contador and Mouzon is
underway and it is exciting beyond
belief and absolutely insane so stay
tuned for that if you do enjoy these
Demon Slayer videos make sure to smash
that like button to let me know if you
have and be sure to subscribe and this
is absolutely crucial hit that
notification bell because if you don't
you will miss future demon slayer videos
if you want crucial updates on the new
demon slayer movie and if you want to
help decide what videos i make next make
sure to follow us on instagram at anime
up roar you can find a link in the
description there will be spoilers in
this video I am talking about the latest
chapter chapter 182 after all now
without further ado let's jump into one
of the most intense and craziest
chapters ever I'm not going to lie this
is one of the best and most hype
chapters in demon slayer in my opinion
we start out where we left off last
chapter time drawing gu art facing off
against moves on we have some nice
colored pages which is perfect because
this is arguably the most important
moment in the manga the talking has been
taken care of in the last chapter now is
the time for action we are told that
standing in front of a being with such
cold feelings like Mouzon causes
tangelos hatred to boil up from deep
inside his body now this wouldn't be a
big deal for everyone but for ton zero
the insanely happy gentle and kind
hearted dude this is significant it's
like when a tough jerk cries in anime
when tundra is angry you know it's a big
deal and you can't even blame him for
losing his cool because Mouzon is the
main antagonist who is to blame directly
or indirectly for the deaths of tangelos
family and friends he also turned us go
into a demon it's all been leading up to
this so it's no surprise that Tundra has
trouble keeping his cool for the first
time he gets a chance to fight and
possibly stop the being responsible for
all of his suffering and the suffering
of many many others as we're told early
on in the chapter
Mulan cannot be killed even if his neck
is cut he has gone beyond that he is
almost immortal almost he is still
vulnerable to the sunlight the Sun can
still kill him which is why he's after
Nez
the only demon that has become immune to
the Sun at this point it seems like
there is no way for moves on to be
defeated after all they are in upper
moon for nakamise dimensional infinity
fortress there is no sunlight available
here and knock you may can in theory
make sure that moves on never exists the
safe sunless environment so yeah at the
beginning of this chapter moves on seems
straight-up invincible and unbeatable
tundra thinks to himself that they have
no choice but to wait for everyone to
arrive as kiria directed they have to
stall moves on until the Sun comes up so
they can hopefully get him out of the
fortress somehow and beat him they also
have to find out any useful information
they can about Mouzon and deliver it to
everyone else tundra is not delusional
he knows that the best he and ghee you
can do is survive until the others
arrive and then that is when according
to him the real fight will start I
really like this about Demon Slayer it's
not uncommon Shonen anime that you have
o P main characters regularly taking on
multiple opponents and eventually
beating them but almost every fight in
Demon Slayer has been dependent on
teamwork it's almost always multiple
weaker demon Slayers fighting against
one stronger demon it's almost never a
matter of one character just becoming
strong enough to kill the strong
opponent on his own like Goku versus
Frieza
it's always this well thought out group
effort that results in a demon slayer
victory usually they win without any
individual character actually becoming
stronger than the demon they just
defeated this is what makes the fight so
epic and interesting and that is why we
know that this moves on fight against
all of the strongest pillars and even
sayers is going to be amazing the fight
begins with moves on using his crazy
tentacle-like arms to attack the two
demon Slayers keep in mind he still has
that calm face he had during the last
chapter he seems bored in a shirt of his
victory Mulan's arms have crazy reach
and speed as gu says his arms are like
extremely fast flying blades he uses law
but obviously that won't completely
protect him from moves on if it couldn't
even protect him from a cosa puncher is
having trouble following the arms with
his eyes so he asked to try sensing them
through his sense of smell he succeeds
in getting close to moves on and even
dodges his next attack it seems like
he's finally making progress and
and something shocking happens just as
it seems like country is going to land a
significant hit on booze on just as he
thinks it is possible for him to avoid
Milan's arms he gets slashed in the
right eye I could barely believe this
when I read it it is not common for a
protagonist to lose his eye but this cut
looks Dee it looks like even if Conchita
survives this battle he's going to have
a one-eyed Zorro look for the rest of
his life this head drops Tonto to the
ground he has to be saved by Q who tells
him not to close the distance he reminds
him that they don't need to get in there
and that moves on strength can't be
compared to an upper moon even the
strongest ones hue mentions that there's
no cover they are completely at risk
moves on as calm as ever he's dictating
the battle after all he asks if they are
waiting for the Sun and reminds them of
what we already know that the sunlight
won't reach into the fortress he asks if
they really think they can manage that
with just three pillars this is a
surprise because there should be more
Gil Mason Amy Guillaume it's early yet
agura why did he say three then he says
that meets would be the love pillar and
agura the snake pillar are dead they've
already been killed by upper moon four
remember that Muslims connected to his
demons and he can see what they see or
even what they are thinking
we even see a visions of the two pillars
and they're completely out of commission
it wouldn't be the first time that
pillars have died so it actually seems
possible however this immediately seemed
like a genjutsu to me it had to be some
kind of illusion I didn't know how they
managed to do it but it didn't seem real
after all we were constantly told how
upper moon 4 was annoying but pretty
much harmless and there is no way that a
guru the snake pillar would die without
showing us what he's got so I was
hesitant to believe this but there isn't
much time to think about it because the
epic fight ensues as we've seen time and
time again demons are at a huge
advantage compared to demon Slayers
because they can regenerate quickly from
wounds while humans cannot this is why
time zero tells himself to not get his
ankles cut because that would put him
and you at risk one proper slice of the
ankle which would be nothing to a
regenerating demon could put him out of
commission for good
so demon Slayers had to be way more
careful than demons even though he's
trying his hardest
Thundra is having more and more trouble
it's hard for him to judge distance with
just one eye
so again he needs to rely on his sense
of smell he tries to access the
see-through world again but he doesn't
succeed according to him Mullins attacks
are too fast and Tundra can't keep up he
even runs out of breath the worst thing
that could happen to a demon slayer then
to make matters worse conjure hits into
a wall he was so preoccupied with the
fast moving arms that he didn't notice
his surroundings gia screams he thinks
it's all over for tons it off and
remember that's a big deal for him this
bromance goes way back
do you help Tundra when he was helpless
and even staked his own life for Tangier
oh and mezu ko that's how much they mean
to him and now it really seems like it's
all over
tundra even thinks that it's no use but
then Mitsui comes in breaking through
the wall yelling knock it off she is
adorable as always moves on is shocked
that she's alive as is ghee she gets a
direct hit on moves on but moves on is
completely fine meet Surya shocked when
her attack has no effect in fact
according to myth Suri
she's never been more shocked in her
life we get a hilarious illustration of
her freaking out which offers us some
much-needed comedic relief at this point
then we jump to a guru who is protecting
Tangier oh and looking as cool as ever
he tells Tantra that he'll just get in
the way and that conjurer should leave
control seemingly ignores his comment
and just says that he's so glad that
meets woody and agudo are alive egora
tells him to focus on himself rather
than worrying about others which makes
sense since he does seem to be in the
worst condition right now moves on is so
surprised that the two pillars are alive
even though he's seen them die that he
loses his cool remember how calm he was
before all of the tides seemed to be
turning because now his face is full of
emotion he's mad that Nike may failed
him and that he was misled then we jump
to naki Mei who is being an jutsu by you
Shiro himself this was an amazing moment
for me you should all was so angry after
moves on kill Tamayo the most important
person in his life I said in that
chapter review that I really hope he
plays a part in defeating moves on but
even as I said that I had no idea how he
would come in handy during a fight
against such a strong opponent and now
that he has taken control documents mine
I think it's the perfect way for him to
get his revenge against moves on after
all if you really think about it
nakamise Mullins only weak spot he is
invincible inside this sunless
forretress but the sunless fortress is
only available when nakooma is doing her
thing now that you should was
manipulating her vision the demon
slayers can use nakamise Opie abilities
for themselves and turned them against
moves on as ushiro says two moves on he
committed the greatest sin in this world
when he took Tama yo son away from him
this guy who is way weaker than moves on
even claims that he'll make the demon
king of pop kneel and regret what a
fricking boss you should have turned out
to be the mangaka did an amazing job
with his character tundra realizes that
the whole fortress is bending and you
shoot Oh with tears and anger in his
eyes Vale's that he will drive Mulan
above ground that's the end of this
chapter and what an amazing chapter it
was in theory now you should all be able
to use machi Mays teleportation ability
to send moves on outside of the fortress
then moves on will no longer be safe
from the sunlight it truly is an amazing
twist I love how things have completely
changed over the course of one chapter
we went from a calm moves on completely
wrecking conjuring you who were both
freaking out contro even appears to have
lost one eye the two pillars meets for
the any guru were supposedly killed and
tangelo was just about to get killed and
that's when everything flipped they went
from seemingly no hope to a clear path
of defeating moves on the two pillars
showed up you should have took control
of na ki main and most importantly moves
on losses cool which was amazing to see
no matter how small he sees that there's
a chance of him losing now which is why
he's no longer completely calm cool and
collected
I love how even when things seemed
hopeless for tantra and ghee you they
kept fighting even when they had no idea
how they would get moves on into the
sunlight they still continue to fight
trusting that a path would reveal itself
eventually that's a great lesson for
life even when we don't know exactly how
we're going to accomplish a huge goal or
dream if we just don't give up and keep
working on it eventually things will pop
up that we didn't foresee and they will
help us get to our desired destination
as Paulo Coelho wrote in The Alchemist
when you want something all the universe
conspires in helping you to achieve it
obviously you need to put into work have
patience and perseverance but if you do
all that then you'll find that things
pop up to help you exactly when you need
them in this case tons you're kept
fighting and trusting that the universe
would provide and
that came in the form of you she rose
amazing genjutsu similarly at the
beginning of this year I made it a goal
for this channel to hit half a million
subscribers before the end of the year I
wasn't sure exactly how we'd get more
subscribers this year than we ever got
before when I wrote down the goal but I
trusted that my brother and I could find
a way to accomplish this and as of now
we're already over five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers and it's not
even the end of the year yet it was the
same when we just started taking YouTube
seriously and we decided to turn it into
a full-time job even though we only had
about six hundred subscribers and we're
making zero dollars from it at the time
if you want to achieve a goal I found
that you need to put in the work
exercise patience and perseverance and
trust that the universe will help you
out along the way
that is what Tantra did and as we can
see it paid off gloriously the fight
isn't over but moves on seems a lot more
vulnerable now than he did at the
beginning and middle of this chapter
that's for sure and that is it for this
one a chapter of you complete with some
life lessons to boot thank you so much
for watching and for supporting this
channel everything we've achieved here
would not have been possible without the
space fam which is what I like to call
the community we built around this
channel if you did enjoy this video make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is extremely important hit that
notification bell so you actually know
when the next video comes out for more
Dimas air content and crucial updates
about the new movie and seasons you can
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar a big thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro here or
to your patrons the one and only
gilgamesh baby Rae nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings out just fitted ala
beat Anatole cos at Sookie DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
plans Steven and Rana al-hola autumn
Maddie back to 3:9 makoto-kun and the
world if you enjoy our work you can
support more way by going over to
patreon economy up for and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patient only discord so check out
patreon accomplished and me out drawer
link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube
let's support more content that way if
you prefer thanks for everything and
until next time see us bass Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]